This is hilarious. I was sent a link yesterday
to the David Pakman show on Yelp. Now you're
probably thinking why is the David Pakman
show on Yelp? Yelp is a website. It's usually
for restaurants, maybe sometimes for other
types of businesses, pest control or whatever.
Why is it that the David Pakman show is on
Yelp? I don't know the answer. Usually it's
was your food good and did the waitstaff treat
you well? All of that stuff, I had no idea.
But there's an entry for the David Pakman
show on Yelp in North Hampton, Massachusetts,
which is where the show started years ago,
but is of course no longer base.
Hilariously were listed under radio stations
and television stations, neither of which
we are. Uh, there were only about 10 reviews
as of yesterday. I hope that you'll help us
add some hilarious reviews to this and also
add some pictures. There are no pictures as
part of our Yelp profile. Some of the reviews
are surprisingly a bad. J J from Eustace,
Texas reviewed our show by saying, quote,
this dude just wants to criticize America
and all its inhabitants. He wants to tell
you how bad it is there. If all people in
Argentina think like him, it is a perfect
reason why Argentina has one of the most corrupt
and useless excuses for a country. One could
imagine he really should try to clean his
own house, Argentina before he goes to another
country and points out someone else's minor
issues. That actually sounds a lot like what
Donald Trump recently said about those for
a democratic congresswoman.
Um, a British should have taken over that
piece of s country during the fall clin island.
But kicking the Agile Tinian took God, save
the Queen. Uh, Charlie W's review different
just saying good atmosphere, but terrible
pizza. Anyway, this is ripe for Hilarity,
so please check it out. We're linking to the
page on our youtube clip, but you can also
find our Yelp page by going to yelp.com search
in North Hampton, Massachusetts and type in
the David Pakman show. I predict that a week
from now we will have lots of really, really
funny reviews from our audience and probably
a lot of negative, excuse me, negative ones
as well.